apple has announced that it will add
hundreds of new emojis to its ios system
including a person at a spa a vomiting
face and a shushing finger
finally giving emoji fans the ability to
describe what it was like to work for
harvey weinstein
right um last one last one come on guys
our next presenter starred in netflix's
bird box
a movie where people survive by acting
like they don't see a thing
sort of like working for harvey
weinstein
you did it you i didn't you did it
to begin i just want to congratulate
harvey i'd like to thank harvey
weinstein
harvey weinstein harvey weinstein harvey
weinstein harvey and bob weinstein
harvey weinstein and then harvey
weinstein harvey weinstein
harvey and bob weinstein thank you
harvey weinstein
i want to thank harvey and bob weinstein
my agent kevin euvain and god harvey
weinstein
[Applause]
it was reported that one of harvey
weinstein's lead attorneys
is withdrawing from the case after he
finally googled harvey weinstein
i got to tell you harvey weinstein was
probably the first person that i ever
looked at a photograph of and was like
yeah he raped
[Laughter]
not sure this [ __ ] has a choice
[Laughter]
not a handsome man not a lot of meat and
extra skin on his face
he's ugly you know the sad part is he's
done so well in life
he probably doesn't know exactly you
know when you're good looking
everybody will tell you oh you look
wonderful you're so great looking
when you're ugly you got to figure that
[ __ ] out for yourself
it's a lot of putting clues together who
it is
why am i not getting in the club i got
all the right [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
cause it was brad pitt doing that [ __ ]
he wouldn't hurt a peep
the girl just come back down like i got
the part
yuck
and yet and yet it is important that i
acknowledge ladies
you are absolutely right
there you go
they gotta all be mindful of that guys
because uh
this could happen to any of us it
happened to me
i can see that i see myself showing up i
am
here for my 3 a.m with mr weinstein
hey harvey i got your text i'm here to
talk about the script
[Laughter]
seems like it's gonna be hard to read
and candlelight but i guess i could try
sound like a [ __ ] nightmare could you
imagine that [ __ ]
did you imagine using a business meeting
and a [ __ ]
pull their dick out
in the middle of the meet i'll be like
yo yo
my man it's the most unprofessional [ __ ]
i've ever seen
in all my days
just let me finish dave chappelle
put you in all three lord of the rings
hurry up [ __ ] i have other meetings you
know
i have a 4 30 a.m in brett ratner's
house
i believe it's wardrobe fitting
anybody hear this guy harvey weinstein
yeah yeah i mean it's unbelievable and
i'm saying
first of all when did this guy have time
to make movies i don't know
i thought movie making was hard come on
no but you know this guy
uh it's an unbelievable story and i said
you know all these guys
who do sexual harassment they're i mean
they're freaks
this big fat guy what does he think
he says to a woman here's his standard
move according to all these women have
accused him they they go
he goes listen i'm going to get in the
shower i want you to watch me
nude now i'm a man if you saw me naked
you'd throw up
there is no girl on the planet that
wants to see harvey weinstein naked and
is going to get aroused if i was harvey
weinstein i wear a burka
and i say listen you don't have to look
at me
i mean what who puts this logic together
right
think about it
[Applause]
[Music]
what else has been happening did you
hear about what happened to harvey
weinstein
i really did bendigo no he hasn't come
here
already mums are safe right
harvey weinstein after he's you know
been
publicly outed as like a serial rapist
yeah he did horrible things he's been
accused by almost 100 women right
harvey weinstein was invited to a show
to support young actors and comedians
yeah [ __ ] right and so he showed up
with an entire
entourage of people for some reason he
still has friends
don't really know why he was sitting
with a whole bunch of young women i
guess they can't read
everyone who was performing was told do
not say
anything about harvey weinstein right so
it was a very tense environment and then
this female comedian
she got up and she ignored the rules she
looked at harvey weinstein and she
started to rip him in front of
everyone his friends started to boo her
and then she got kicked out of the venue
along with every single other person
that said something to harvey weinstein
and everyone is calling this woman who
stood up to harvey weinstein
a brave woman she's incredibly brave and
i do agree with that that's very brave
and i think that's amazing she's done
that but
do you know what's even more brave than
that woman
inviting harvey weinstein to your show
that's [ __ ] brave the dudes raped
like 80 chicks and you're like come on
help me come to my show
where everyone will see give me your own
booth
there are a lot of brave people in the
world but not that brave
firefighters are brave they risk their
lives running into flames pulling out
women and children from fires
i don't think any of them would invite a
serial rapist to a dinner party
like what would happen okay guys come on
into the party come and sit down this is
harvey weinstein
oh [ __ ] you invited him
did you know he's a rapist yeah i didn't
i sat next to my wife
[ __ ] that's brave
you know who's even braver than the
person who invited harvey weinstein out
harvey weinstein for leaving the house
what the [ __ ] is he doing what did he
think was going to happen
that's a brave [ __ ] but [ __ ] that guy
it's a bit of a new bit for you cuz
that's good all right harvey wants to
point that on twitter see if it gets me
canceled
australian comedian calls harvey
weinstein brave hero
look at this big story out here in
hollywood the big scandal ha
happy weinstein right
first of all dude i mean what a display
of power to finish
in a potted plant and then have the
nerve to call the person the next day
saying hey you know i had a great time
i mean that's out of your [ __ ] mind
and i don't get these [ __ ] people
uh where everything i'm gonna go to
rehab
how do you go to rehab to stop you from
preventing a woman
leaving a room taking your dick out and
coming on a fern
do they have rehab i didn't know that
what are you in here for
oh you know i uh i [ __ ] blocked an
exit and [ __ ] on a plant
oh yeah yeah me too me too well i guess
we're gonna be buddies here huh
you know and they just in this wing of
the rehab where there's no potted plants
they got buddies outside the [ __ ]
window trying to sneak [ __ ] plants in
for him that is the most bizarre [ __ ]
story
but um that's not what i want to talk
about here you know what i mean were
they [ __ ] sitting there going all
i love when they said all all of men in
hollywood kept silent it's like
everybody did and they were acting like
harvey weinstein couldn't ruin the
career of a guy
that guy up until four days ago could
take your career
wad it up right in front of you and
throw it in the gutter and you were done
you were [ __ ] done you're talking
about a guy
whoever allegedly could block a woman
from leaving a room
and then coming on a plane and then
[ __ ] does the follow-up call like
like
they went to dinner in a movie and they
had a lovely time that's the level of
power this guy had
human beings should not have that level
of power by the way because man or woman
they they do not handle it well um but
anyways let's get back to as far as like
you know
being able to see both sides of the
fence here our sports fans are just like
you know that's obviously holding and
then if the holding call doesn't go
against you it's like oh no no
[ __ ] great call great non-call fox
news
they were going off on [ __ ] harvey
weinstein and all hollywood and how
underhanded and blah blah blah blah
but when trump was grabbing the [ __ ]
they got nothing
right and then [ __ ] cnn's the same
[ __ ] way
trump grabs the [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
all [ __ ] over it
harvey weinstein does what he does this
isn't a time to [ __ ] politicize this
thing
they're both so [ __ ] full of [ __ ] and
they're gonna judge all of hollywood on
harvey weinstein
right the same way the liberals judge
all republicans on donald trump
i i don't know how anybody uh
watches either one of those channels
however i will say this
because i don't watch fox news that
often i don't really watch cnn
but i will at least cnn it looks it
looks professional
i'm not saying it is well it is but i'm
not saying it's it's obviously not
ridiculously biased they both are but
what is fox news looks like i don't
it looks like [ __ ] wsbk tv 38 back in
the day when they go in between periods
and their little [ __ ] set i don't
know what about fox news it's like they
got to put more money into it
everybody looks sweaty you know i don't
understand it
um but anyways jesus [ __ ] christ
uh so now they're going back into
everybody's life they're going back into
somebody else you did this back in 2000
here's my thing all these guys are now
gonna have to apologize
for all the [ __ ] they did evidently back
into the [ __ ] 90s or whatever
my question is is uh when is the when is
it going to even out
uh i would love to see some gold digging
[ __ ] come on and apologize and be like
yeah hey
sorry i took your house and had a couple
of kids with you and said that i loved
you when i really didn't
uh i should have done that and then
prevented you from seeing those kids
that you had with me that half look like
me and you now know that i never really
loved you
and uh i'm sorry for that and banging
the new guy
in this house that you bought and now
i'm also not gonna
uh you know have my new boyfriend ever
move in or marry me because then my
payments from you and the alimony will
stop i i want to apologize for that my
behavior was completely
unacceptable
just to balance it out